The most well-known heuristic for
graph partitioning is
the Kernighan-Lin algorithm.
By the way,
the g in Kernighan is silent.
That's gnu as in the wildebeest,
not the the free software thing,
which has a hard g, as in ga-nu.
So it's gnu, not ga-nu.
Got it?
The idea behind the K-L
algorithm is simple.
Given a graph, divide the vertices
into two subsets of equal or
nearly equal size.
Yes.
Any split will do.
I'm serious, any one you want.
It's okay.
Go ahead.
Oh, for goodness sake,
just pick a partition already!
Let's define the cost of this
partitioning to be the number of edges
that go between V1 and V2.
Now imagine that a magic bean hands you
two equal sized subsets of V1 and V2.
Let's call these subsets X1 and X2.
Imagine that you were to
swap these two subsets.
Naturally you would expect
the cut size to change.
But by how much?
To answer this question in a formal way,
let's start with some definitions.
Consider one vertex, let's call it a,
which lives on one side of a partition.
Define its external cost
as the number of edges that
land in the other partition.
In this cartoon,
a's external cost, denoted E 1
of a is equal to three edges.
To find a similar external cost, E 2 of
b for any vertex b that lives in V 2.
Next, define the notion
of an internal cost.
The internal cost will count
the number of edges from a vertex to
other vertices that live
in the same partition.
>From these definitions, you can write
down the cost of a partition as follows.
It's the cost of the partition, ignoring
a and b, plus the external cost of a,
the external cost of b,
and minus some constant.
So what's this constant?
You need that constant to account for
a possible edge between a and b.
The constant is one if there's
an edge there and zero otherwise.
But why subtract it?
That is a terrific question and
you should take a moment to ponder it.
Now suppose you swap a and b.
What's the new cost?
Well, any edge that was
incident on a that was
previously external is now internal.
Same thing goes for b.
So to get the new cost, let's start
with the old cost, ignoring a and b, and
then add some adjustments.
The adjustments involve
the internal costs of a and
b plus the constant again.
Hey, what's with the plus constant, now?
Now let's look at the change in cost.
That's the old cost minus the new cost.
After some algebra, you get this.
The larger this change,
the better, because it means
a larger decrease in the cost.
Let's call this cost the gain
from swapping a and b.
By the way,
do you see that it's possible that
gain of ab could actually be negative?